(bright music)
All season long we're highlighting
hometowns all across the country
because there's no place like home.
Next step is Seattle, Washington.
Where Marlie and Anthony Love call home.
The Love's love Seattle and I have a
feeling we're about to also watch this.
Hey Drew it's Anthony and Marlie
and we're in front of Pike Place Market.
Located in our hometown of Seattle, Washington.
Drew we love Seattle so much.
Not just because of the great scenery
and great coffee but there's some
places that mean so much to us personally.
So come with us and let us show you around.
(upbeat music)
We are at the iconic Space Needle.
A signature staple for the Seattle skyline.
Of course it's iconic
but it's personal for us because
on our first trip to Seattle in 2015
this was the spot when we decided
that we were gonna move to Seattle.
And now it just represents the
love that we have for this city.
Welcome to Boon Boona Coffee,
Boon Boona is a local Seattle coffee shop
that specializes in African coffee.
Before moving to Seattle
we only drank the name brand stuff.
But locals told us aye you have
to try a local spot Boon Boona was
the first one and we fell in love.
[Marlie] Now that we got some coffee let us
take you to another spot that is personal to us.
We're in front of Alki Beach
one of many beaches located right here in Seattle.
Yeah there are so many beautiful
beaches in Seattle you really can't go wrong.
But Alki is our personal favorite.
Not only because it was the first
beach that we visited when we moved to Seattle
but look at those breathtaking views.
Also visitors can play
volleyball, walk, run, or ride
on the paved path laid along the beach.
On top of all that right
across from the beach are great
options for food and fun with plenty
of restaurants, bars and shops.
Alki beach, another reason why we love Seattle.
Well Drew that's just a snapshot
of this beautiful city of Seattle.
We hope you love it as much as we do.
We can't wait for you to come visit!
See you soon!
I love you Love's and by the way
I never go to Seattle without hitting
Pike's Market and having a bowl
of the best clam chowder ever.
Oh what a wonderful place, I love Seattle!
And hometowns and I love this country!
(upbeat music)